- I was in high school and
we were looking at a film
and it was looking at the degradation
of homelessness and disparity.
And I said, wow, man, those
people are really fucked up.
I'll never end up like that.
And about two years ago,
I was on one of the back
streets here on Skid Row,
and it dawned on me what I said.
And I said, I'll be damned.
I became one of those people.
- All right, Norman.
Norman, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from Detroit, Michigan.
- And tell me about your family.
You had both parents growing up?
- No, I had one parent.
Didn't know my father, didn't meet him
until the day before my 18th birthday.
Came out here,
grew up in the Country Club
Park district of Los Angeles.
- At what age?
- 14 months old.
Went to 24th Street School,
had two very smart sisters
that I had to follow behind.
I always liked to read.
Got straight A's in elementary school.
September the 2nd, 1976, devastating.
I watched my mother take her last breath.
She died of a massive cerebral hemorrhage.
My grandmother came from
Detroit to take me back.
- You saw this?
- Yes.
- How old were you?
- I was 12 years old.
- 12, Jesus.
- 12 years old.
- So you went back to Detroit?
- Yes, went back to Detroit.
To describe my grandmother a little bit,
six foot two and a half,
295 pound Sequoia Indian
born in Moose Head, Saskatchewan, Canada.
Very strict.
I wouldn't say mean, but very ruly.
When I was 15 years old,
something devastating happened to me.
A family friend molested me,
threw me down and inserted hisself in me.
I never told anybody, never told anybody.
Graduated from high school,
Detroit Northern high school.
Straight A's, most likely to
succeed, and best dressed.
Won the Adlai Stevenson Award
to go to Baylor University.
Graduated in three years
with a Bachelor's of
Science in computer science.
I had before then applied
for the Fritz Kreisler Award.
I won it, went to Michigan.
Graduated magna cum laude,
and I started working
for Ford Motor Company.
Switched over to General
Dynamics, it was more money.
When I was about 24 and a half, 25,
I discovered crack cocaine.
My first time, I went and
drew $5,000 out of the bank.
I didn't go back to work and
that started my downfall.
I've put myself in very
precarious situations,
gay men have come up to me and
asked me for sexual favors.
I've done it.
I lost my grandmother in
1985, which was another blow.
- And you're not gay.
- No, I'm not gay at all.
Totally, totally straight.
Nobody's ever inserted themself into me,
with the exception of
the guy who molested me.
But I've put myself in positions
to where thank God that I don't have HIV.
You're looking at a
person who's had it all.
Through the course of my addiction,
I've lost six houses,
one condo, five cars.
My average salary is anywhere
from 95 to 245,000 dollars a year.
- Now you're living on the street.
- Yeah, and now I'm living on the streets.
My nightly routine usually consists of
going on the Metrorail to either
Long Beach or Santa Monica
because they're the longest ones.
Once they put you off of that,
then I'll get on the bus.
Either the 33 or the 60 and I'll ride.
- It's safer to ride a
bus or a train than...
- Yes, yes. Than to be on the streets.
You have so many precarious
situations that happen.
It's a catch-as-catch-can
when you're homeless.
You never know what's going to happen.
You never know what the next move is.
So I've been a crack cocaine addict
for the better part of 32, 33 years.
- You have kids?
- I have four kids.
Ranging from 32 years old to nine.
Of course, right now,
they don't hear from me.
I had a phone and I was jonesing,
and then I sold my phone
after I spent $253 to get it.
It is what it is.
I've been in recovery before.
I've been in about 55
different treatment centers.
Longest lift in sobriety I've ever had
was six years, 10 months, and two days.
I blew that because I got cocky,
I thought I had it.
I haven't been able to
muster up 90 days since,
and that's been about 18, 19 years ago.
Homelessness is systemic.
It's something that you
really don't plan on,
but you quickly learn
how to adapt and survive.
Well, when I was young,
I was 16 years old,
I was in high school and
we were looking at a film
and they were looking at the degradation
of homelessness and disparity.
And I said, wow, man, those
people are really fucked up.
I'll never end up like that.
And about two years ago,
I was on one of the back
streets here on Skid Row,
and it dawned on me what I said.
And I said, I'll be damned,
I'm one of those people.
But I looked at the fact
that I said those people,
so I categorized somebody.
Well, everybody's human.
Everybody makes mistakes,
everybody has downfall.
It's up to you.
Right now, do I want to quit using drugs?
My heart says yes, but my body says no
because I have the type of disease
that centers in my head
and at a moments whim,
I could be doing good.
I've walked off jobs.
I've stolen from jobs.
I have a slew of employers
who've wondered what the hell happened
because here's a guy with
all of this potential.
I've worked here on Skid Row before,
only to go back time and time again.
Do I know what the future holds?
No, I'm not God.
Do I believe in God? Yes. Do I pray? Yes.
But I was once told when I was
a young kid by my grandmother
that God will give you
whatever's in your heart.
So if drugs are in my heart,
that's exactly what I'm going to get.
If I want to change, it's up to me,
but I really, really
have to really want it.
Right now, do I want it?
I'll be honest, no.
To be quite honest,
I really don't know what the hell I want.
So I'm at one of those
pinnacle crossroads in life.
It's a damned if you
do, damned if you don't.
So I really don't know
what the fuck I wanna do.
- How do you support yourself now?
- Well, I get general relief.
I get food stamps, which I
usually sell every month.
And then I have to put
myself in a position
to where I have to go in food lines,
which I don't have to.
You get $194 worth of food stamps,
you sell them for a hundred bucks,
you buy crack, you buy weed, you buy beer,
you buy cigarettes, you're broke.
This usually happens,
if I get some bad dope,
it usually happens within hours.
If I get some good dope, it
might take a couple of days.
Am I employable?
I believe I am employable,
but with this addiction, no, I'm not.
No way.
First check.
They had a nickname for me
in the rooms of cocaine anonymous.
They used to call me one check Norman
because every time I would get a job,
I get sober, I get a job.
First check, I'm gone.
That's it.
And that's happened for the last 14 years.
- You're a rare case of someone
who's educated and successful
and then ended up here at the bottom.
What do you think most
people don't understand?
What most people outside of this world
don't understand about addiction?
- Its strength, the power.
It's very, very powerful.
Anytime your mind can convince you
to fuck yourself without permission,
without your permission.
That's bad.
And this has happened time and time again,
but I have no control over it.
It's something that
centers right in my mind.
I could be doing good one minute,
I might do good for months,
but there's going to come a day.
And I know it is.
- Something stressful?
- Sometimes. Majority of the times,
it's always something
that nudges me to that.
One time, my daughter didn't want
to talk to me for some reason,
I went and used.
I got into an argument with a coworker,
It could be anything.
The bus driver could piss me off,
I'll get off the bus before my stop
and go to the dope house.
It really doesn't matter.
I think people just
don't really understand
how powerful the disease of addiction is.
It's extremely powerful.
- Do you think there was
anything in your childhood?
Like what happened with the molestation,
sexual abuse or anything like that?
Or do you think it was the
environment that you were in?
- Well, I grew up in a
damn good environment.
In Detroit, I was basically sequestered.
- But somebody introduced
you to crack cocaine.
- Yes, I actually volunteered
at a homeless shelter called COTS.
It was on Michigan and Trumbull
right by the old Tiger Stadium.
And this little girl used to
come up to me all the time
and I'd give her candy
and then her mom came up to me
and she actually talked
to me about her story
and I felt real bad and
I moved her in with me.
One time her cousin had a problem at home
and they needed somewhere to stay,
and I brought them there,
and one day I came home and
they were smoking crack.
The room door was locked
and I said, no, I don't want any.
They offered it to me, I said no.
I said that for three consecutive days.
The fourth day, I tried it.
That was 1986.
This is 2020.
Since then, it's been an up
and down battle, a zigzag.
I call it sometimes perpetual rondo.
It's up, it's down, it's in between.
People that know me have always said
you have a wealth of intelligence.
Well, I've all come to realize that
I'm probably the smartest
dumbest motherfucker
I've ever met in my life.
That's a shame, but it's the truth.
See, I've come to a point
to where I'm a realist
and I understand what I suffer from.
I don't understand it fully,
but I understand it enough that
it's more powerful than me.
And will I do this till I die?
I don't know.
Do I want to die a cocaine addict?
No, I don't.
Do I want my kids to be mad
at me like they are now?
No, I don't.
Do I want all of the shit
that's happened to me?
No, I don't.
It's really fucked up when
somebody of the same sex
forces you into something.
Even now, my eyes are almost welting up
because you just don't
do that to somebody.
I think that's one of
the reasons why I use.
Even having sex with other men,
I've questioned my own sexuality.
Am I gay?
No, I'm not, but I needed a hit
and they offered me money
and I knew I could get a hit,
so I did it.
Am I proud of it?
Hell no.
But I think the more and
more I talk about it,
the freer I'll get.
Hopefully and prayerfully,
somebody will see this
and understand that,
guess what?
You can have it all.
I've been to Park Avenue,
now I'm on a park bench.
I've had the riches, now I have rags.
But it's up to me, choice is mine.
- Have you talked about
these things before?
- No. No, not really.
People only know about my schooling.
They know about my family.
My last name is Fondren.
I'm not even going to
say anything about that,
I'll just have you look up the last name.
It's a family that dates back to 1218.
It's a family that has a family crest.
It's a family that's extremely prominent.
I have not lived up to that billing.
I was bred and coded to do that,
but for some reason I got
attracted to the street life
because it was something that
I was always told not to do
and it seemed like as I'm going to church
as a young kid with my grandmother
and as I'm being sequestered
and have to come in
when the lights are on,
everybody else is having fun.
Thank God for my
grandmother, she warned me.
Everything she ever told me has come true.
She said, if you get with those people,
you're going to be
exactly like those people
and the only way you're
going to go is down.
And that's what has happened.
- Have you lost touch with
all your friends and family
and things like that?
- My immediate friends, yes.
They don't really want
to be bothered anymore
because they know that I'm going to lie
about something to get some money.
My family,
my oldest sister understands a little bit.
My middle sister,
we don't have the
relationship we used to have
based on the fact that
I stole her wedding ring
and her husband's wedding ring
after she sent for me to come
out here in the first place.
How did I repay her?
Just like I repaid everybody else.
Just like I've done everybody else.
Fuck them.
When the disease says go, I go.
- What do you think the
solution is to your situation?
What would help you if you were
ready to change and wanted to?
What do you think would be the first step?
- Well, I think the first step
is being honest with myself
and understanding that
I do have an addiction.
I do have a disease.
Understanding that it's
more powerful than I am.
I do in some respects, but
I don't respect that shit.
I don't give a fuck.
If I could take a hit right now, I would.
Do I want one right now?
You damn right, I do.
Because that's just how it is.
But I gotta be honest within myself
and be willing to stop
and be willing to change.
Am I afraid of that change?
Yes, I do have fear of the unknown.
I've come to grips with that.
If I can't see it, taste it, and feel it,
I ain't fucking with it.
But yet again, I act on faith.
If they say faith is the
substance of things hoped for
and the evidence of things not seen,
a friend comes around the
corner, his eyes are wide.
He said, Hey man, they got some bomb.
Now, it's a substance of things hoped for,
so I'm hoping to get like him.
The evidence of things not seen,
I didn't see the crack,
but I went and I acted in faith.
So faith works in various ways,
you gotta really look at that.
I just gotta be willing to change.
I gotta be willing to want
to stop getting high, period.
It's just not crack,
I don't need anything.
If I drink a beer, I'm
gonna smoke some rocks.
If I smoke some weed, I'm
going to smoke some rocks.
If I think about smoking some rocks,
I'm going to smoke some rocks.
So I gotta be honest with myself
and I gotta be willing inside, in here,
to say, Hey Norman, enough is enough.
You would think at 56 years
old that I would learn.
Doesn't look like it.
- What's the most important
thing you've learned
from your years on the street?
- How to survive.
It's a bitch being hungry.
Hunger is something that's
very, very fucked up.
It doesn't get to the depths
of the third world countries
where people are starving,
starving, but I've been hungry.
I've ran out of Ralph's with
a fully cooked slab of ribs,
baby back ribs, chicken.
I went in 99 cents stores
and ditched a security guard
and stolen candy just to eat.
I've eaten out of the garbage can.
I've seen a drink at a bus stop
and I've looked around and I've drank it
because I was thirsty.
But two days earlier, I just
had four, five hundred dollars.
So I've learned how to
survive, most importantly.
- What regrets do you have?
- My regret is July the 19th, 1986.
That's when I took my first hit.
I regret doing that.
I've often looked back and said,
if I would've never done that,
but if if was a fifth, we'd all be drunk,
the cliche's go on and on,
but if I would have never taken that,
where would I be now?
At that time, I was working
for General Dynamics.
I was 23 and a half, 24,
making $74,000 a year.
Had one of the best apartments
that you could see in
Detroit, the Jeffersonian.
That's where I stayed,
right down on Jefferson.
I look over my balcony,
I'm looking at Windsor,
Canada and the Detroit River.
Now, I'm looking at
rats, I'm smelling piss,
and I'm stepping over people,
and struggling every day to survive.
I'm struggling every day to eat,
I'm struggling every day
to smoke a cigarette,
I'm struggling every day to get a hit.
My regret is July 19th, 1986.
- Do you see any signs that
you're getting close to making a change?
- I don't know.
I was talking to my buddy and
he looked at me this morning,
he said, man, what's wrong?
I said, man, I'm really
getting tired of this.
He's like, Norm, I've
known you for a long time.
He said, man, you smart,
you can come out of it.
I said it ain't got a damn
thing to do with intelligence,
has everything to do with wherewithal.
I think God and I have a problem.
Yeah, cause I'm a mama's boy.
It always happens when
I talk about my mom,
because that was fucked up
that I had to watch that.
I always think about her.
She was lighter, way lighter than me
and I look just like her.
And a lot of times I think
she's really not proud of me.
So that's it, we're gonna do our best.
- All right, Norm.
Well, good luck, man.
- Okay.
- Great speaking with you.
- Wow. That's the first
time I did that one.